hey 42 here Sir Isaac Newton is
universally regarded as one of the most
brilliant men who ever lived during his
84 years on God's green earth he did
more than perhaps anyone else before or
since to further our understanding of
this crazy Universe we live in
in a book titled the 100 published in
1978 Newton ranks as the second most
influential person in history putting
him one place above Jesus Christ the
actual Son of God
[Music]
many of History's luminaries were only
fully appreciated after their deaths but
not Newton he was a legend in his own
lifetime a force of nature whose
superhuman intellect illuminated the
darkest recesses of human knowledge
knighted by Queen Anne in 1705 he later
became the first scientist buried in
Westminster Abbey a final resting place
traditionally reserved for the monarchy
it was the scientific equivalent of
sainthood
all of this is of course common
knowledge when you're one of the
greatest thinkers in history word of
your achievements tends to get around
but there's another side to the knighted
Newton that you didn't learn about in
school a shadowy Mr Hyde to the genius
to Dr Jekyll
you see Newton spent Decades of his life
conducting top secret research that even
his closest colleagues and confidants
knew nothing about and there was good
reason for that because had anyone known
what Newton was really up to Behind
Closed Doors he probably would have been
locked up perhaps even hanged
his descendants considered this
clandestine research to be so dangerous
that they buried it for centuries when
it eventually resurfaced more than 200
years after his death it unveiled the
unexpectedly Dark Shadows cast by one of
science's brightest lights
this is the untold story of Sir Isaac
Newton a scientist mathematician genius
and heretical Alchemist
[Music]
like the man he pipped to Second spot on
the list of the 100 most influential
people in history Newton was born on
Christmas Day the birth of a child is
typically one of her family's most
joyous events but Newton's was a little
bit different his father also called
Isaac had died three months earlier and
Isaac Jr arrived several months ahead of
schedule he was so tiny when he gulped
his first breath of Earthly air that his
mother claimed he could fit inside a
quart mug hopefully someone from America
can tell me what the hell it actually
means in the comments if Newton's birth
was bad his childhood wasn't much better
when he was just three years of age his
mother left the family home the shack up
of director of a nearby Village
abandoning Isaac to the care of his
grandparents perhaps unsurprisingly
Newton would grow up hating his
stepfather's God-fearing guts and his
relationship with his mother suffered as
a result
oddly enough Newton wasn't actually such
a great student as a youngster he only
started taking his studies seriously
after deciding the best way to prove his
Worth to his many bullies was to show
them that he was smarter than them it's
fair to say that went pretty well still
had history taken a slightly different
course Newton might never have become
the Giga genius he ultimately did
because in 1658 his mother pulled him
out of school and tried to force him to
take over the family far luckily for us
Newton's Schoolmaster managed to change
her mind and the young genius ended up
at Cambridge where he delved into the
fields of Science and Mathematics rather
than actual fields the rest as they say
is history by 24 Newton had established
the fundamentals of calculus discovered
the complex multi-colored nature of
light and started work on what Would One
Day become the universal theory of
gravity
at an age where most of us are still
figuring out how to work the washing
machine Isaac Newton had fundamentally
altered Humanity's understanding of life
the universe and everything had he made
just one of these breakthroughs in his
career he would have gone down in
history as one of the most important
scientists of the age the fact he made
all three and countless others besides
is why we consider Newton to be perhaps
the most important scientist of any era
and that's pretty much how he was viewed
for a good 200 years after his death
but on the 13th of July 1936 the world
got its first glimpse of an altogether
different side of this simply scientist
that was the day that brilliantly named
Gerard Vernon Wallop known to his mates
as the nine fell of Portsmouth put the
contents of a large metallic chest up
for auction at silverbees in London
the junk in this metallic trunk
consisted of thousands of pages of
handwritten notes by Newton himself
these never before seen manuscripts
containing a colossal 10 million words
represented the sum total of Newton's
life work but barely anyone knew they
existed before that day
Newton died without a will and the
wealth of his writings wandered to his
relatives who after scanning the
contents decided it was best for
everyone if the manuscripts disappeared
if you're wondering what convinced the
nine full of Portsmouth to break with
200 years of family tradition by
offering Newton's papers up for public
auction the answer is simple
it's broke 10 million words straight
from the pen of the greatest scientist
in history should have been priceless
but oddly the auction attracted scant
attention
for some reason the folks at silverbees
did bugger all to advertise the sale and
ultimately Newton's life work was sold
piecemeal to dozens of different
collectors for the poultry sum of just
nine thousand pounds amongst the buyers
that day was legendary economist John
Maynard keys he turned up late having
only heard about the marginally marketed
auction at the last minute and as a
result he was only able to snag around
10 of the papers but what he discovered
in those pages was so remarkable he
spent the final decade of his life
trying to track down the rest
despite Newton's reputation as one of
the greatest scientists and
mathematicians in history those subjects
are counted for less than a third of the
writings he left behind in other words
all that invention of calculus and
discovery of the laws of gravity
business was basically a side hobby he
dabbled in when he wasn't working on his
real interests namely religion and
Alchemy
after two the former would have been the
most controversial in Newton's time
because the roughly 5 million words he
dedicated to the subjective religion
revealed views that the Christian Church
would have considered nothing short of
heretical Newton was a closet
anti-trinitarian meaning he rejected the
idea of a god separated into the three
equal parts of the Holy Trinity
according to Newton Jesus Christ was
just another man and worshiping him was
tantamount to idolatry in 17th century
England that was a very dangerous
Viewpoint indeed people had been
executed for far less
despite his radical religious ideas
Newton was a deeply spiritual man and
devout Christian he was also a bit of an
egotist believing he'd been hand-picked
by God himself to reveal ancient wisdom
hidden in the Bible
for years he fixated on finding the
fabled Bible Code a hidden Cipher that
would reveal long-lost knowledge about
the nature of the universe
in a manuscript dating to 1704 Newton
used Clues he found in the old
testament's Book of Daniel to
scientifically calculate the timing of
the Apocalypse though unable to pinpoint
a precise date he did predict it will
come sooner than 2016. I can't decide if
that's comforting or terrifying Newton's
religious views may have been heretical
but his alchemical interests were very
much illegal practitioners of alchemy an
Antiquated arm of natural philosophy
sought to transform base Metals into
gold seek a miracle cure-all concoction
or Brew The elusive elixir of Life which
was basically Red Bull but if you drank
it you'd live forever Alchemy was a
pinch of protochemistry a smattering of
sorcery and a massive dollop of
delusional but Sir Isaac Newton
was absolutely bloody mad for it
amongst the papers auctioned in 1936 was
a detailed description of how to make
something called sophic Mercury which in
Newton's day was believed to be a
precursor to the Philosopher's Stone the
key to eternal life
Newton conducted countless experiments
over the course of 30 years as a
dedicated Alchemist and whilst he was
never successful in transmuting lead
into gold his alchemical obsession may
have had an unexpected but profound
effect on his life and Legacy more on
that in a moment
oh and if you're still wondering exactly
why Alchemy was illegal in Newton's day
allow me to explain if someone ever
figured out how to turn base Metals into
gold they would have the power to
single-handedly break the entire English
economy
nobody knew for certain if transmutation
was actually possible but in 1404 Henry
IV made some aspects of alchemy
punishable by death just to be on the
safe side
whilst Newton's more outlandish studies
were almost entirely unknown to the
outside world until the auction in 1936
even in his own time he had a bit of a
reputation for being well a bit odd he
was an introverted child and a reclusive
adult with very few friends at 19 he
confessed all his sins in a letter he
wrote To None of her than God himself
whilst most were laughably innocuous
like squirting water on a Sunday I'm
definitely going to hell if that one
counts others reveal a darker side to
the Scientific Saint of the 17th century
amongst his 57 sins Newton confessed to
punching his sister fighting wishing
various people dead and threatening to
burn his parents house down whilst they
were still inside
lovely
Newton also had a famously volatile
relationship with many of his fellow
scientists probably his most famous
dispute was with German polymath
Gottfried leibniz who Newton believed
had plagiarized his development of
calculus
the bitter Feud spanned years and turned
pretty nasty prompting the prestigious
Royal Society to intervene in a long
guns detailed report published in 1713
the society ruled in Newton's favor but
there was a catch Newton just so
happened to be the president of the
Royal Society at the time and he wrote
the entire scaving report himself
without ever bothering to ask leibniz
for his version of events incidentally
most modern Scholars now believe Newton
and leibniz developed calculus entirely
independently so it was all a lot of
fuss about nothing
[Music]
as a professor Newton taught at
Cambridge University for some 30 years
but he had little interest in passing on
his knowledge to the Next Generation he
made no effort to dumb things down for
the mere mortals taking his classes and
his lectures were so impenetrable that
most of his students didn't even bother
to turn up not that newton-minded
according to Legend he delivered his
lectures regardless of whether or not
anyone was actually there to hear them
Newton's famously erratic behavior only
intensified with age and in 1692 he had
a full-blown nervous breakdown for 18
months he battled insomnia mental
confusion Tremors digestive issues
memory Melodies and paranoid delusions
modern Newton Scholars have speculated
that he may have suffered from one or
more conditions bipolar disorder
depression Asperger's syndrome and
schizophrenia but it may also be the
case that Newton's secret research
contributed to his psychological
imbalance because those symptoms I just
mentioned insomnia confusion digestive
issues
they're all signs of mercury poisoning
Mercury was an important substance to
Alchemists and Newton would have used it
in many of his experiments being the
thorough and slightly balmy scientist
that he was he even tasted it along with
over 100 Metals including Arsenic and
Lead
to add a little extra weight to the
heavy metal poisoning theory on his
death at the grand old age of 84
Newton's hair was found to contain
extremely high concentrations of Mercury
in his mid-50s Newton was appointed
Warden to the Royal Mint the role was
supposed to be symbolic more a sign of
status than an actual job but Newton had
other ideas to the extreme annoyance of
his new colleagues he took his purely
symbolic job incredibly seriously
bowling in like Elon Musk at Twitter and
making wholesale changes designed to
reduce corruption and inefficiency
counterfeiting was a huge problem in
England at the time and Newton
vigorously pursued the prosecution of
those suspected of the crime rumor has
it he even visited London's dodgier pubs
in Disguise in an attempt to gather
evidence on local coin-based criminals
he was responsible for dozens of
successful convictions and many of those
he brought to Justice were hung drawn
quartered and finally disemboweled for
their crimes
he continued to work diligently in this
job that was never supposed to be a job
for almost 30 years only retiring when
the Grim Reaper paid him a visit in the
spring of 1727.
history remembers Newton as the ultimate
scientist a pure intellect whose
remarkable insights ushered mankind into
a new era of understanding and he
certainly did exactly that but like
every other member of the species he did
so much for Newton was also a man he
made his fair share of mistakes and did
battle with more than a few demons and
yes he may have been a little bit
different but then again perhaps you
need to be if you want to change the
world
thanks for watching